Hi, I'm Pavni Diwanji.
I'm a VP at Google.
I work on Google for Kids.
If I had a chance
to go back in time
and meet myself as a young
girl, what would I say to her?
I would say, be
curious, be creative.
Math and art are two of
your favorite subjects,
and that is fabulous.
Keep tinkering.
Cultivate your passion,
because that is going
to be an amazing life for you.
The second thing I
would say is, remember
that friend that came and
said, clever isn't cool?
Don't listen.
Don't worry about what
other people have to say.
You have a very strong core.
Just focus on what you want to
do and what your beliefs are,
and the rest will
take care of itself.
And then the third thing I want
to say to you is, you are bold.
You're outspoken.
And yes, that means sometimes
you get into trouble.
But that's OK, because bold
means you can think big.
You can go on adventures.
You can follow paths that
no one is going to follow.
And that is what is
going to make life
an amazing journey for you.
So be you.
Don't change.
You're perfect.
Thank you.